be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so getting into getting back in the
DC Comics what I want to do here is I
want to start year of the villain now
technically speaking we already kind of
started it when we covered Justice
League like the apex predator story and
I've spent a little while assembling and
basically figuring out what the
chronological and and you know slash
reading order for year the villain is so
if you're interested stay true to the
channel we're gonna just basically start
releasing things in chronological order
so we can kind of make it all make sense
up but this one basically picks up with
one of the one-shot now the one shots
for you or the villain are devant
designed to kind of focus on the
characters um in reality I'm not a
hundred percent sure in terms of what
the significance is outside of kind of
basically saying like this is an event
that's going on and you're the villain
and will basically perpetuate the plans
of Lex Luthor right - kind of a symbol
this giant ensemble of a legion of doom
of his own and then kind of go forward
with his grand plan which we'll see play
out you know as the event goes on but
this one basically deals with Sinestro
now Sinestro is by and large probably
one of my favorite villains in the
entirety of DC right because he's not
two-dimensional and it's one of the
things I always loved about Sinestro
Sinestro especially when you get into
Jeff John's run before that it was kind
of like he's okay but you get a Jeff
Jones like the Sinestro Corps war and
you get into like blackest night
brightest day and basically all the
stories that come after sinestro's
probably one of the most intriguing
villains out there because with Sinestro
he genuinely believes he's doing the
right thing right I mean those guys were
unfamiliar the motivation behind
Sinestro is the universe is chaotic
right like like there's no real order
there there's no real structure and if
people do not want to implement their
own order in structure then he will be
forced on them right and again it's it's
one of these arguments that kind of
makes sense you know if a lack of order
and a lack of structure results in like
the the rise and fall of societies by
their own self-destruction then like of
what good is freedom to them right like
freedom's useless to a dead man
especially a dead man that got himself
killed along with a bunch of other
people right so like if people don't
want to be organized and structured
they'll be made to be organized in
structure and so again it's one of these
things worse like preserving society is
the most important thing even if people
don't want to they'd rather just destroy
themselves right I mean that's kind of
the byproduct of the argument the
Sinestro makes them in kind of a product
of freedom is we have the right to
destroy ourselves well no like you
believe you do but you don't get to make
that call for everybody else and so it's
a cool little thing here because what
this does is this basically picks up
with Sinestro essentially being sent to
to a planet in the universe by Lex
Luthor himself
and the reason why is because there's
these beings that are out there that
basically are traveling from like one
planet to the next and like wiping them
out or at least destroying them in order
to basically stop the plan of Sinestro
now this really feels kind of akin to
like the actions of the builders from
Jonathan ich mins Avengers in New
Avengers but on a smaller scale and
that's why it's kind of crazy because
what you end up having here is basically
kind of like this God king of this
planet that exists out there and then
internally actually bails on his people
like when his world is being raised he
just takes off on on all those guys now
what we end up learning is this group is
this jumping from one world to the next
and destroying them this group is called
the Paragons and so when Lex Luthor
travels to this world and ends up facing
off against him and fighting these guys
he ends up realizing they can instantly
heal themselves right like they can
instantly return and basically you know
be restored and so what he is up doing
is basically getting with with you know
some of the forces here on some of the
forces that were kind of left behind or
at least are have been keeping these
guys at bay it says like I want to know
who's running the show and then I also
have a sample of one of these guys and I
want to test it I want to see what's
going on and what we end up learning is
that inside these Paragons or basically
these beings called microns at least as
what Sinestro calls them and these are
kind of like this small society really
system this massive society that lives
an astronomically small life inside of
these beings right and so it's kind of
it's kind of intriguing because to all
the individuals inside each one of these
Paragons the Paragons themselves are
their entire world now they're not
oblivious to them right like they know
who the Paragons are and they serve them
because it's what it's the only thing
they know and it's the only thing
they've been taught you live and your
life lasts 0.8 milliseconds but over the
course of your life you exist to serve
the Paragons to heal them as they need
it and if you do this long enough and
you'll become you'll basically be deemed
as a worthy person right a person who's
done good deeds for the most part like
they don't know anything else right like
they have no idea about anything else
and so is it's it's intriguing here
because when Sinestro learns this what
he does is create these infinitesimal
facsimile of himself and then send them
directly out into you into the ship of
the Paragons and then in turn like
infiltrate the Paragons themselves and
start talking to the microns and this is
one of these these interesting scenarios
because what we end up having here are
the microns who basically prefer the
life that they live right now where it's
basically like Sinestro spec simply
showing up and saying hey look like you
guys shouldn't be doing this the Lord's
that you serve where you believe you
don't know their motivations you don't
really know what they do but you believe
they're benign beep try their God so
they go out and they do
great things they do kind things and
they make the universe a better place
the reality is they're going from one
one location to the next
raising worlds right I mean they're not
from that universe they're not from the
main DC Universe they're from another
location but still they're travelling
from one even one planet to the next
raising like raising all these different
worlds and destroying them like they're
they're literally inflicting death and
destruction on a universal scale and so
when they're basically told this by
Sinestro the response is yeah but like
that's what we do they like like we're
worried we're here to fix them like if
we keep doing what we're doing then like
eventually they'll praise us right like
if we keep doing this long enough
they'll praise us and it's one of these
cool things because we're Sinestro tries
to show them and say look like you're
not really doing things to make the
universe a better place instead the
response is it's just what we do right
they don't know anything else
and so as semester witnesses this
release as one of his facts Emily's
witnesses this ultimately he ends up
bailing on the guys saying hey
everything's gonna be fine you know
leading a behind to basically die but
you know with with one of these guys one
of these are these these you know
microns more or less it kind of laments
the fact that it's been its entire life
working and never really got to know
anybody around it so it's kind of like
an allegory sort of a stand-in for like
the modern day person right like the
modern day American like you're born
into the world and then you go to school
you go to college hoping that you'll
will be able to get a job when you get
out and then when you do you've grind
away for 30 years hoping that like your
life will amount to you the ability to
retire and then you die
the thing that kind of gets missed here
and the reality is there's a lot of
nuance in-between right like we fall in
love we fall out of love we make friends
so it's really not as heavy-handed as it
would seem at least if it's critiquing
us critiquing one part of society and
not really society at large in terms of
all the things that kind of make our
lives worth living but it's really kind
of an exercise and manipulation because
when this happens all the facts similes
of Sinestro come back and it seems that
all of them is failed but then one of
them said that he actually succeeded or
at least he found a way that he believes
can work trying to convince these people
that they're wrong is not the way to do
it right because they're believers right
they are diehard believers in their
cause and you can't change the mind of a
person who's beyond hope and so as a
result of that this guy basically says
like spending time with them and
learning them and seeing that all they
really do is like work and then die
there's a way for us to win and the way
that we can win is to grant them a
longer life and so that's exactly what
Sinestro does right like Sinestro
basically goes through and basically
says like I can extend your life by 0.2
milliseconds and with that 0.2
milliseconds it's basically like it's
like you're getting a whole nother 100
years of your life basically like almost
doubling the amount of
you can live and the question is what
could they do with all that time and so
right off the bat because of the fact
that this works all the other microns
essentially follow suit and in turn they
stop repairing these various guys and
the reason is it really because they
turn their backs on their lords I mean
they kind of do to a degree it's really
rooted in the fact that like there's
other things that they can do now their
sole purpose is not to heal these guys
and then die their sole purpose is to go
on and experience the world and it's a
genius maneuver because what Sinestro
basically does is he sits down and he
says if they're going to basically
remove their belief in these gods in
time they will form new ones and the
reason why is because with any organized
society if given enough time he will
basically start to self-destruct insofar
as people will start creating rifts
they'll start treating reasons for why
you're different from them and why
that's a bad thing and that's that's the
nature of how it works right it's a
nature of any organized society that in
this society and these this this world
of microns they served a singular
purpose and their life wasn't long
enough for them to really get out there
and experience the world or at least to
experience what all life had to offer
but with music comes critics of music
with a longer life comes the development
of philosophies different ideologies
religions different things like that
political movements like this is not
fair we should find a way to change this
so on and so forth and in doing so
basically moves them into a stage to
where ultimately they're gonna need
someone to lead them they're gonna need
someone to control them so when it
basically look up to you and say this is
the reason why we're able to live the
life we live even if it is not
necessarily the best that we could
imagine this guy gave us a longer
lifespan in effect Sinestro becomes
their new God and with Sinestro becoming
their new God basically he's able to to
kind of curtail them and say let's start
moving them away from this philosophy of
just kind of living life in a way they
see fit and let's quote unquote give
them a purpose what these people really
fail to seem to kind of understand or at
least fail to gradually grasp is that
over time they're being made to go right
back into the world that they were in
before if they just don't know you give
them freedom and then slowly slowly
creep them back into into a landscape
where it's they're working just as long
as they ever worked but they don't see
it that way they see themselves as
having freedom but they really don't
it's just an illusion that's been given
to them and as long as they're allowed
to continue believing in that illusion
everything will essentially be fine
right so they're you know in reality
while it is an illusion they're the
ability to wake up from it is also there
they send me just choose not you they
just choose to believe in this lie
they're being told and then move forward
accordingly right so in that regard it's
a critique of society but one of these
Paragons has basically left a lot right
like one of these Paragons remain
and that's where what's left of this
micron society essentially resides here
and as a result of that this particular
Paragon is now a servant essentially to
Sinestro
Sinestro basically tells this guy so
long as you serve me these microns will
continue healing but I'm their God now
and so if you decide not to do what I
tell you to do my facsimile inside your
ring will tell them everybody just kind
of go back to what you were doing before
don't worry about healing this guy don't
worry about doing your job just go and
enjoy and live your life and also going
to take is just a really good loss of
energy and this Paragon is dead right so
by virtue of his own self-preservation
it essentially just kind of continues on
and and basically becomes a servant or
functions as a servant of Sinestro now
Lex Luthor looks at this and says this
is where Sinestro falters because where
Sinestro believes this guy will be a
servant to him the reality is that if
this guy knows what's going on inside of
his own body with regards to these
microns and this facsimile of Sinestro
leading them they're also going to take
is for him to eliminate that facsimile
return himself to being the leader of
these microns and then take that war -
Sinestro now in reality
Sinestro would probably be able to
defeat him assuming that he had other
aides but the fact remains that
basically sinestro's kind of got an ally
on his side this seems to be working
personally for him a bodyguard as it
worked that he could use if he wanted to
- almost face off against against Lex
Luthor and try to basically overtake his
rule now of course whether or not that
would happen would be contingent on
whether or not Lex Luthor is willing to
maintain the views of Sinestro and so
far as allowing him to continue doing
what he's doing here with this promise
of returning order to the universe and
and so on and so forth that much we
don't know but it's a really cool story
in reality I think it highlights
Sinestro at his best right an agent of
like manipulation and in
cloak-and-dagger tactics very smoke and
mirrors very you know things like that
but really showcases his intelligence
his ability to manipulate people into
achieving a particular goal but with
that being said guys we're gonna read
this video to an end if you are new here
- comments explained make sure you guys
at the sub button - become part of the
robb for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later please
[Music]